we have 1 000 minecraft players on this
server and one zombie that is chris
every single time chris kills somebody
they spawn as a zombie
and if this video wasn't cool enough as
is tony's here i
don't want to die whoever is last
remaining gets 10 000 in bitcoin what
if you're the last one remaining i'll
give your channel a shout out that's all
i need i'm gonna win
oh these kids thought they were getting
away huh go chris go
i'm only going after this guy i have to
prove myself now oh
oh oh he died from fall damage
you're ruining their game of ball no get
out of here the zombie horde's coming
oh god okay here we go boys they're all
following me stop it
stop it please is there water under that
crane because if there is then i might
go up it have you noticed this green
circle around you chris
yes if the zombies leave the green
circle they get teleported back in it's
so they stay together
it's not because the server will lag no
it's because zombies together strong
zombies on the street what will they do
they sipping coffee right now this is
where tommy was earlier
i've got a whole gang i think staying in
a building is gonna be the way i'll die
man i'm gonna run like a free man
like a big lad dude this dude's just
chilling in the window get him
oh we got him in a corner the pig what
it's like but with sunglasses
oh my god i just watched somebody fall
to their death oh this dude's just
joking he's
joking this is for ten thousand in
bitcoin and i just don't think this
guy's taking it seriously
this is no laughing matter oh look at
all these nerds to kill
ah they killed me
[Applause]
tommy made fun of chris for dying i
killed like eight people with that so
get out of my
face carl you know who you didn't kill
tommy chris
here's a little hint tommy's in a tree
i'm almost up this tree now
where should i go now can i make this
jump oh no
oh my god that's like half my health
dude i've got to be super careful then
over a tenth of the people are now
zombies yeah we're working fast
why is it dang he killed you oh my god
he hits me once and i go flying back 10
blocks
i don't know if the zombies are faster
than normal players because if they are
i might be
absolutely screwed i'm doing good boys
i'm doing good
leave a like if you think i will win
this human
put a zombie skin on that's cheap who
will win the hot villager or the
camouflage zombie
you have successfully infected one
quarter of the server i'm letting my
boys do the work hey don't forget that
guy back there guys come on what are you
doing
okay this way this way this way to the
woods to the woods i made a good choice
going here first no one is safe
no one is safe i can't see anything
because there's so many freaking zombies
right in my face
there's a guy up there kyle how do i get
on this roof how do i get on this roof
i don't know oh okay am i going to die
if i drop down here
oh my god that has so many hearts wait
why is there a water but
just in case you're cheating i wouldn't
cheat you know what happened last time
chris cheated right
no don't do it we banished him to the
toilet no
i am sentencing you to 10 minutes on the
toilet no
carl here's the camera go film yourself
on the toilet
pillage away oh my god so what i'm
thinking i do
is i jump down right before the zombies
get here and just all of them splatter
and die
they're all over here there's literally
like a clump of a hundred of them you
see that kid down there are you about to
make the jump
you missed horribly you are not even
close this is the worst day of my life
i'm so
bored do the zombies have health uh yeah
you can kill i think i have a plan i'll
make it worth it for you carl
me and my gang 500 players have been
infected which means only 500 remain
i'm halfway done you have a massive
zombie horde now come on my zombies
let's go on guard there's so many
zombies
i'm pinned down i'm pinned down just me
and you rosie rosie rosie move very
carefully oh
there's so many they came just barely
walking over us
if i just stand near it the zombies get
teleported up there accidentally
yo go jordy yeah kill them
you're stuck in the cobwebs this is way
more fun than participating in the
minecraft video i came here for
chris yeah tommy and his gang have just
been sitting here forever
i'm killing other people i'm starting to
think i made this city a little too big
hey give us a shrink we're gonna barely
not
go go go go go go go okay go i got to
make this wall bucket worth it oh my god
no all my friends
come on the other side of the phone go
go go go go boys go there's so many of
them come on mr duck 420 go
right zero knight you're a random mr b
subscriber right yes zero night if i die
i want you to
clench this water bucket from my corpse
uh okay
there's about to be a heavy clash
between the survivalists and the zombies
we're marking them get popped up
e-boy mc's just standing afk in the
middle of the horde and no one's paying
attention we'll get him later
400 remain oh night
we don't have much time we do not have a
shot here follow me for me we got to
lose as many people as possible
oh no get up tommy and his boys are
somehow on the side of a building on a
scale of one to ten i wonder how mad
tommy would be if i just lit a bunch of
fireworks here
i bet you he's freaking out why did he
fall why is he why are you doing this
jimmy
no no no we gotta go up higher we gotta
go up higher all right my only goal is
to get tommy in it now
what what is wrong with you oh you don't
like the fireworks i thought it'd be
entertaining
oh wait the zombies are here oh snap are
you ready you ready
i gotta go i gotta go we gotta go i
gotta go tommy you're getting chased i
wonder what would happen if i just did
this give me no please stop it please
it's got this one guy yo it's tommy look
down there there's a horde of zombies
oh my god yeah we are clearing these
places out
guys let's go together we strong zombie
game
your punishment's over if you want to
come back all right
please never again just don't cheat is
it not there's a zombie that oh i oh
it wasn't me it wasn't me it wasn't me
they're oh
it worked i sat on a toilet for like 15
minutes it was so
worth it it was so worth it the borders
are shrinking that's good for me yo
tommy's over here
i see him come on hard i'll try and
direct them away from me jimmy kept
doing fireworks that was the worst oh
well i'm like literally staring at you
that's not the opposite i'm gonna get up
at his level so that way my zombies
spawn on the tree with him watch this
tommy's at the peak hundreds of zombies
are surrounding him
i'm sending my soldiers get away from me
oh they can jump and hit him oh oh
toby
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no oh yeah go go go go go go go get him
boys get him get him oh get him oh yes
yes
he's on top of the car oh
no he's gone and he died
oh my god no i'll never get my shouts
out you die
ah i guess i'll have to kill people now
oh my god dude actually i'm killing so
many people
big tommy the nether right zombie over
here okay
here we go oh
not mr biggie cheese no dude chris i'm
up here you want me to try and jump on
him get him tommy
oh i believe in you you got this tommy
oh
every other one look at all those
zombies using the water
go my children it's raining zombies oh
they're hitting them
let's hit the top i'm ready
we gotta there's two right here and then
two on these rails
four people remain oh gosh four people
two we've gotta get them we got to
two left there's only two left chris i
see him i get him tommy
mlg oh no oh tommy
you decide who gets the ten thousand
dollars of bitcoin someone is gonna hate
me for the rest of their life
okay here we here they come oh he's
going for the hot dog hd
yo oh oh oh my god
hot dogs dead oh my god oh my god
wait wait what oh my god
wait what just happened how did that
zombie get up there
they jump from the top look up there oh
my god
what is up marshy i was shaking
10 000 worth of bitcoin send me your
address will get you the money
and you are now rich my dad is going
crazy right now he made less money than
you today let's go
the video will end in exactly five
seconds what do you have to say
subscribe to mr reese and
sharpmasterbeats.com